[Music]
kenyatta real in the suburbs of madrid
is one of the biggest slums in the
european union
here some 8 000 people live in extreme
poverty
and through the coldest of winters in
recent years about half of them have
been living without electricity
in temperatures as low as minus 10
degrees centigrade for months
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
part of the almost 90 billion euro
european social fund plus
has been set aside to ensure children in
the eu don't have to endure such
conditions
the esf plus will ensure that that funds
are available
to support citizens in difficult
situations to provide
opportunities for training and
unemployment to ensure
that every child and youth is given the
opportunity to succeed
every single member state will have to
allocate enough funding to address child
poverty
countries with high levels of child
poverty will have to spend at least five
percent of esf plus resources on helping
them
in areas ranging from access to free
education
to decent food and housing
[Music]
helping young people into work
especially in the wake of the pandemic
is another priority of the esf plus
investments in apprenticeships and
vocational training will help them
access
quality jobs countries with above
average youth unemployment should invest
at least 12.5 percent of funds to help
young people
into the workforce the fund will also
provide food and basic assistance to
those most in need
and promote social inclusion